hi
my name is atlas
and i just completed mark's
accept yourself 2.0
we just ended on a
very powerful guided meditation
by mark
both that meditation as well as this
entire program
have been super
catalytic in
my radical self-acceptance
in my
radical
love
to all of my conditioning
the radical love to all
the separation
to all of the feelings of unworthiness
the feelings of wanting to be seen
and having the radical
self-acceptance and love
to
those feelings
is exactly what enables me
to
holistically
transcend and include them
as i elevate
my frequency my consciousness
more and more into the god state
mark is very masterful
at
personalizing the guidance
of enabling
people to see
beyond their cloudy obfuscations
and have
the inherent
luminous sunlight
of god
fully re-emerge
as 100 worthy
as 100 already
full and then enabling
them to step forth and radiate that
luminosity for our world
i'm very impressed by mark i'm very
impressed by the accept yourself program
i'm super excited
about accept yourself three and beyond
and to help be in service and
shepherding
so many others to come through this
process
to catalyze the ignition of the global
awakening
and i highly recommend mark i highly
recommend his accept yourself program
again this has been atlas checking out